sup guys ran right over here
Tyrone Magnus Tyrone big buff beautiful
black man with the biggest [ __ ] the
world has ever seen
has done some video that I mentioned in
that mag explains how to defeat the
react astok for including himself I
don't know what the [ __ ] were about to
watch I guess the react astok for Tyrone
Gator rejects and a kiss on the costume
I forgot how to say I met the guy
several times you don't know how to say
[ __ ] I know right here
that's cool the Wonder needs to be
better than me
this is security letter Omega password
Delta charlie
- 2 7 - 5 - 1 9 39 enabled new protocol
toggle Agra met no contingency should
any of the core members of the react
astok 4 turned rogue we need to have
plans in place to handle each and every
one of us should we become a threat the
members of the big four are my teammates
but we need to be prepared for the worst
always Agra mental contingency file
codename red dreads
acha son the black man from Japan he
brought us all together it's because of
his innovation that the reactor
community has come together and it's the
same innovation that can make him a
powerful adversary if he were to turn
against us that's a big goodbye boy his
dreadlocks series needle into channel
buddy and he'll be powerless AG remember
no contingency file codename reject yes
ii have subscriber power only to taro
magnus himself
orion right would be a very dangerous
opponent worried to turn this home or
write jokes but like most strong name
his weak spot would most likely be his
woman taking her hostage would surely
emotionally distract him that's true
neutralize him for good
that's heroine with his gay jokes Eggman
no contingency
file codename crocodile gator Martin was
the first reactor active noticed before
discovering the rest he has a strong
subscriber base and a worthy sidekick
Fuli their friendship seems to be strong
so taking coolly as a hostage with
crippling emotionally also because of
reactors main power comes from being
able to see what they are doing
destroying gators glasses should
neutralize him from reacting for a short
while a well time to blow to gators
faceplate should do the trick
footnote I have no contingency by
codename carbonation while not a member
of the big four speaking in his own
words
Jenks is a good reactor which is just
one reason it will be difficult to face
him in combat should be turn against the
big four it's not bulky that relish but
if it must be done the following
strategy could be used freely because it
gives competitiveness if he could be
convinced to be done each of us which
brings us to Agra no contingency by
codename Wow
aka those motors counterpart aka the
Blackie bogie son of a [ __ ]
it's a goddamn every actor incompetant
he is still half human the best way to
disable his reacting abilities would be
to separately distract him his hair
sensors useless crippling him from
fulfilling his madness eases sexual
fantasies in between reactions with him
sustaining a blow to his male ego in
this way you'll become withdrawn and
unsure of himself neutralized by his
inability to perform he could then be
captured think carefully before you do
this you watched the most amazing thing
ever
what are you - oh my god that was like
idiotic brilliance at its best his
script on it was so [ __ ] funny yeah
the details were brilliant oh man you
really got me pretty well man that was
pretty funny and the weak spot thing was
actually true does the whole concept of
it was hilarious I think it's a parody
of another video regardless the script
was brilliant dude that was a funny ass
[ __ ] video Tyrone normally I review a
video I go into a review what I think my
reaction really sweets word itself well
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe you the real rejects you can
check out salamander Sally's channel
she's also done over 70 videos with me
on the real rejects most
those being trailer reaction reviews you
could follow us both on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter where Sally tweets
photos of her Sally's nipples in the
house she's gotten it's everywhere Liam
Thomas
peachy cool hi Ryan
everything but I've told you before a
while back that you were awesome thought
I'd give you an update
you're still awesome I know this thanks
for the entertainment and the laughs it
really is spirit lifting dude it is
awesome to hear that your spirits are
uplifted I know and just so you know I
do believe in God but I believe in
myself even more honestly you could ask
God for anything sometimes it's like he
doesn't deliver there's a reason why
right you ask me for anything I'm gonna
deliver I am God
Oh Liam get taken down yeah
well that's what's happened what voice
was that